he-man's first foray into theaters in
1987
didn't exactly go as planned but the
once mighty tv and toy phenomenon is
finally poised to get the reboot
treatment
even though the first movie was a flop
the new masters of the universe is far
more likely to blow you away
here's why to say that the 1987 film
masters of the universe was a bit of a
disappointment would be a massive
understatement the movie starred dolph
lundgren as he-man frank langella as the
villainous skeletor and a young courtney
cox as a newly introduced earthling
character named julia winston
cox's character in a way embodied many
of fans major problems with the film
there wasn't anything wrong with the
future friend star's performance per se
but her having such a key role in the
film left fans hugely frustrated for two
reasons
first julia is from earth which is also
where most of the film takes place
by contrast the cartooning comics were
based on the planet eternia
a fantastical land that combined
elements of sword and sorcery with
science fiction
by taking he-man out of that familiar
setting and transporting him to earth
the movie was forced to tell a fish out
of water story that prevented fans from
getting to experience he-man in his
element
secondly julia winston never appeared in
the cartoon the comics or the toy line
she was a character created solely for
the film and she wasn't the only one
despite having dozens of well-liked and
fascinating characters at their disposal
the filmmakers chose to forego them all
in favor of their own like keyboard
playing kevin
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you think sounds great the
creative team behind the new masters of
the universe surely know just what went
wrong with the original
and there's no way they're going to
repeat the mistakes of the past
sorry kevin it may be 2019 but these
days you'd be forgiven for thinking it
was actually 1989.
everywhere you look in pop culture the
decade of big hair neon clothing and
reaganomics seems to be taking over
just look at what's on tv these days
modern reboots of classic 80 series
macgyver and magnum pi are both
important blocks of cbs's prime time
lineup
while abc's comedy lineup is partly
anchored by the 80s set
the goldbergs and the connors a
continuation of the 80s hit roseanne
on top of all that netflix has a voltron
reboot the full house follow up fuller
house
80s wrestling drama glow and of course
the massively popular stranger things
which even got coca-cola to bring back
new coke one of the biggest product
failures of all time is a tie-in
netflix also produces shira and the
princesses of power
a reboot of he-man's female-focused
spin-off series which debuted in 1985.
if anything the movie industry is even
more in love with the 80s
2019 alone has seen reboots of child's
play and pets cemetery
with new sequels for the terminator and
rambo on the way
in 2020 things are going to get even
more retro with belated sequels for
ghostbusters bill and ted
coming to america and top gun all slated
for release
even the upcoming wonder woman sequel
takes place in the 80s
and they're not even being subtle with
that one the film is literally called
wonder woman 1984.
people just can't get enough of the 80s
right now which means the time is right
for a reboot of one of the decade's most
iconic contributions to pop culture
[Applause]
noah centeno probably isn't who most
masters of the universe fans had in mind
for the role of he-man
the young actor has dark hair instead of
prince adam's signature blonde for
example
he's also fairly slight to build and
lacks a bodybuilder's physique
on top of that he's only 23 years old
that means sentineo was born in 1996
long after he-man had his moment in the
sun but despite his appearance not quite
matching cartoon he-man's and his
relative youth
sentineo is who sony pitchers cast for
the lead in the new masters of the
universe
and believe it or not they seem to have
known exactly what they were doing
centennial may not look much like he-man
but he is poised to deliver a memorable
performance as the character nonetheless
centennial burst onto the scene in a big
way in 2018
thanks to his role in the netflix teen
romance to all the boys i've loved
before
before appearing in two more films for
the streaming giant sierra burgess is a
loser and the perfect date
thanks to his charismatic performances
in these films centennial has become
something of an internet sensation
and his likability factor will likely go
a long way toward helping himself his
incarnation of he-man
and it's happened before too just take a
look at chris pratt
he wasn't anyone's idea of a typical
action hero when he was playing chubby
slacker andy dwyer on parks and
recreation but his performance as
star-lord and guardians of the galaxy
completely changed people's perception
of him and now he's one of the world's
biggest action stars
expect sentinel to undergo a similar
transformation
and sure he can work out and throw on a
wig to pull off the look of he-man
but what's really going to make his
performance memorable is star quality
luckily he's got that in spades two of
the hottest genres in pop culture right
now
are science fiction and fantasy for the
past several years the box office is
dominated by the marvel cinematic
universe which has been trending more
and more towards straight up science
fiction
avengers end game deals with time travel
aliens and all kinds of intergalactic
insanity
and of course another sci-fi film avatar
was the top box office earner worldwide
before end game took the crown
on television fantasy is invoked with
the series finale of game of thrones
recently becoming the most watched
episode of any show in hbo history
and with multiple game of thrones
spin-offs in the works along with
adaptations of lord of the rings and the
wheel of time
it seems like fantasy will continue to
dominate tv for years to come
but it's when you successfully blend
those two genres that the real magic
happens
surprise thor ragnarok managed to pull
this off with a plum
by taking thor the most fantasy friendly
marvel character and putting him into a
retro science fiction environment
the movie came up with something truly
special and unique
except of course it wasn't all that
unique because he-man and the masters of
the universe were doing it 35 years
earlier
he-man is about a society on the planet
eternia where magic
and alien technology exist together and
are employed equally
he-man may wield a magic sword and hang
out with a sorceress
but he also sometimes flies a ship that
shoots lasers
fantasy and sci-fi can be tons of fun
when they're mixed together
and given the franchise's
long-established history of doing just
that
the new masters of the universe movie
ought to be a blast
look not everyone likes he-man that's
fair prince adam is kind of a dork and
he-man himself is kind of just a buff
guy with a bad haircut and no
personality
but like the 1987 original this movie
isn't called he-man it's called
masters of the universe masters plural
he-man is part of an avengers-like squad
that bites evil and each one of them is
more awesome than the last
there's man at arms who's a master at
every weapon and has a sick mustache
tila a unicorn riding goddess and battle
cat the armored steed that prince adam's
cowardly tiger cringer turns into
whenever adam becomes he-man
and as cool as the heroes of the
franchise are the villains are even
better
battling against t-man for the power of
castle grey skull are evil doers like
beast man
a hulking monster evil lin a magic
wand-wielding sorceress with a pun for a
name
and trap jaw a cyborg with sharp metal
teeth and an arm that can be swapped out
for numerous weapons
all of these bad guys act as henchmen
for skeletor one of the most iconic
villains in
all of genre fiction skeletor is a
diabolical blue skinned brute with a
skull for a head and an unquenchable
lust for power
for many he's the best part of masters
of the universe and seeing him adapted
onto the big screen using today's
technology
will be worth the price of admission all
on its own
as you probably figured out by now
masters of the universe is a pretty
fantastical franchise
full of all kinds of magic powers
battles heroes and villains
oh and a castle shaped like a skull of
course it was relatively easy to show
all those things in animated form in the
1980s because all you had to do was draw
them
but bringing it all to life convincingly
in a live action movie was always going
to be a far more difficult task
in the 80s cgi was practically unheard
of and most movies were still using
puppetry and other practical effects
puppetry can be fun and definitely has a
strong nostalgia factor nowadays
but it typically isn't the most
convincing visual effect modern movies
have at their disposal
over the past few years however cgi has
finally reached the point where it can
create entire worlds and characters
that are virtually indistinguishable
from real life in avengers infinity war
and its sequel end game for instance
the villain thanos is completely
computer and motion capture generated
despite all that however he still feels
like a real character
his facial expressions and other
movements are incredibly lifelike and at
no point in either of those movies does
he ever feel artificial
using this technology will be the key to
creating a convincing eternium
and the prospect of seeing the planet
come to life like never before
is very exciting indeed
post-credit scenes have become something
of a given with big blockbusters over
the past decade thanks largely to marvel
popularizing the trend
but they've actually been around for far
longer and although they were rare at
the time
post-credit scenes would still
occasionally pop up in some 1980s films
mostly used in comedy to squeeze in one
more joke like a 1980s airplane
1987s planes trains and automobiles and
1986's ferris bueller's day off
which had one of the most memorable of
the decade
you're still here
it's over
go home but then there was also the
post-credits scene in the original
masters of the universe which remains
one of the most notorious
ever made near the end of the film
he-man and skeletor engage in a final
battle that ends when he-man knocks
skeletor into an unfathomably deep pit
skeletor is presumed dead and the film
ends on a happy note
so far so normal right well after the
credits have rolled this happens
it's a tantalizing if slightly lame
promise
and one which was doubtless made by a
bunch of filmmakers who were confident
they'd one day be producing a sequel
but in the end it turned out that
skeletor lied because the film was a
massive critical and box office failure
no sequel was ever produced making
skeletors tease at the end of the film
utterly pointless
but now with the new masters of the
universe on the way skeletor will
finally make his long-awaited return to
the silver screen
and the character will be able to keep
his promise after all these years
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]